Sam, I've been reading Leviticus because
I've finished most of the New Testament
and you know uh I was wondering because
I'm reading it and uh it's saying like
it's talking about the laws of eating
the food and it's saying like you know
obviously the kosher diet and it's
saying
that not only are you not allowed to eat
these things but they're an abomination
to you. So I'm just wondering maybe I'm
you know just because I haven't read
that much Old Testament like where is
>> Deuteronomy 14. Why are you worried
about it?
>> Huh?
>> Why are you worried about Leviticus 11,
Deuteronomy 14?
>> Um, I'm just wondering like what is this
transition? You know, Christ says it's
not the thing you eat that defiles you,
but it's what comes out of your mouth.
>> Oh, that's Come on, that's common sense.
Did God create the pig?
>> Yeah, he did.
>> Did he create it clean or unclean?
>> Did God create the camel?
>> Yes. Did he create it clean or unclean?
>> Clean. [snorts]
>> So then how can any animal that God
created be unclean by its very nature?
>> It's not then. But why does Moses say it
though? This is what confuses me.
>> So then why do you think Moses said it?
So now I'm going to ask you if animals
by their very nature here cannot be
unclean because when God created
everything created it good. That's what
Genesis 1 says. So then what makes a pig
or camel unclean?
Did God make something unclean?
>> No.
>> So then why would it be unclean?
Even though that's not topic, but I'll
still go with it. As long as you spit on
Muhammad. [snorts]
>> Exactly. So why would it be unclean?
Think about it.
>> Post transgression, right?
But why wouldn't then all the animals be
tainted by post transgression?
>> If it's your sin that makes them all
unclean, then why aren't all the animals
unclean?
>> Is it something to do with their hooves?
>> Something to do. No, it has nothing to
do with that. Because again, because
that's what God says. They're hopes,
right? But he could have said no. He
could have said something else was
unclean. So think about why an animal
would be unclean if God made everything
clean. If it had to do with sin, then
sin would affect all the animals, not
just some.
>> You still don't get it?
>> No, I don't honestly because I don't
know why.
>> It's because God said so.
>> Oh, okay. That's where
>> unclean
in of themselves.
What makes it unclean is that you
disobey a command of God not to eat
something. So what's making you unclean
is by eating something God said don't
eat.
>> So it's the disobedience.
>> Yes. So if God says I don't want you to
eat camel meat. I don't want you to eat
pig because pig smells like Muhammad but
but better because Muhammad was a dirty
pig. All right. It's not the pig in of
itself that is unclean because nothing
that God makes by its nature is unclean.
It's the command that you disobey that
will then make you unclean in the sight
of God.
Right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So that's what Jesus is saying.
Don't be stupid and think that eating
physically will defile your mind and
heart and soul. It's not physical food
that defiles you spiritually.
It's your
evil deeds and desires
that move you to act contrary to God
that will then
corrupt, taint
[clears throat] your mind, your
spiritual heart and soul. Do we get that
now?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, that's Jesus's point. So you guys
understand what he's asking you in Mark
7, Jesus says, "Not what you put in your
mouth that defiles you because it's
going to come out. It's what comes out
of your heart." Here he says it in
context.
So then why say if you eat pig meat
that's unclean? It's unclean because God
for a season saying I want you a certain
way. I want you to dress a certain way.
I want you to look a certain way. I want
you to pray a certain way because I want
you to be different from people around
you.
Okay? And then you're going to see what
it points to. And he said to them, "Are
you lacking understanding in this way as
well? Do you not perceive that whatever
goes into the man from outside cannot
defile him?" Defile what? Yeah. If you
eat unhealthy foods, it was going to
destroy you physically. He's not talking
about, oh, you get physically sick,
diabetes or cancer.
It's talking about physical food cannot
defile your spiritual heart, your mind,
your soul. Because it does not go into
his heart,
but into his stomach and goes to the
sewer
and because your body will then digest
and get rid of the excess, right? Purge
the food.
And he was saying that which proceeds
out of the man, that is what defiles the
man. For from within, out of the heart,
meaning your mind, your soul, your inner
thoughts, your inner desires, proceed
the evil thoughts, sexual immoralities,
thefts, murders, adulteries, coveting,
wickedness, deceit, sensuality, envy,
slander, pride, and foolishness. All
these evil things proceed from within
and defile the man. So, does everyone
understand what the Lord is saying? Now,
if an animal is unclean by its very
nature, then you're going to tell me or
I'm going to ask you who made it that
way.
You can't tell me God. That would be an
insult blasphemy to God, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But then if you say, well, the fall of
man, sin, corrupted tainted animals, why
did it only corrupt some, not all?
>> Doesn't make sense.
>> Okay. So, that's can't be the answer,
right?
No.
>> Okay. So then if you guys are listening,
do you want to know why God gave these
rules? And it's the disobedience of the
rules that make you unclean. You guys
want to know why? I know you do, but I
just want to make sure they're listening
and not bored.
I want to make sure they're not bored
because I'm a boring boring person.
[snorts]
>> Allah.
>> Who wants to know besides my friend
here? Have you been curious about that
question? How many of you have been
curious about it?
If you read the penetube, the reason why
God tells the Israelites, "Dress a
certain way, use certain thread, don't
mix two threads, right? [snorts] Pray a
certain way, right? Don't mark your
body." These were all
commandments
to make Israel stick out like a sore
thumb so that they would be so different
from the nations. They wouldn't resemble
the nations that the nations will notice
these people are different from all of
us. So number one, the commands were
given to separate Israel from being like
the nations to stand out like a sore
thumb that they were so different in the
way they dressed, the way they spoke,
the way they ate, the way they
worshiped. It would catch the attention
of the nations. Why are you so
different? Because our God is different
from your God. This is even seen in God
not wanting them to have a human king.
If you read, it's in 1 Samuel 8. They
say, "We want to have a king like the
nations, a human king." But God never
wanted them to have a human king. He
wanted to be their only king and have
judges representing him so they would be
different from the nations. But they
wanted to be like the nations. All
right, that's number one.
Number two, in what I just said, these
different ways of eating and speaking
and dressing and worshiping
were intended to separate them from
the nations. Also applies to animals
because according New Testament, do you
know what unclean animals represent?
>> Uh, no.
the pagans, the Gentiles, and their
practices.
You know what the clean animals
represent?
>> Um, holiness
>> represents Israel who was set apart to
be pure and clean.
>> You [clears throat] want me to give you
the proof because I know you're kind of
slow.
>> I am kind of slow. Yes. I I see it in my
Bible commentary, but I mean
>> I see what you're saying in my Orthodox
Bible commentary just now.
>> What did they say?
>> It's pretty much uh I'll go back to the
last page. It's pretty much saying that
the um
the uh
>> I'll bring you up one second. Go ahead.
Yeah,
>> it says that pretty much the law of
Moses is talking about the animals that
are clean are representing pretty much
the the cleansing of both Jews and
Gentiles and baptism. Okay, see now I
didn't know that. I haven't read that in
Orthodox Study Bible. But guys, do you
understand what I said? What the unclean
animals represent? The unclean animals
point to the nations being unclean and
they need to be cleansed until then be
separate from them. Where am I getting
this from?
Here you go.
Peter. Acts 10:9-16.
You ready?
Now, you think it's amazing, Jacob? You
know how many times I've mentioned this?
Oh, I get tired. Sound like a broken
record telling you, "Hey guys, I've done
this millions of times over and over
again." It's little loser checked out.
So, if you don't go back and listen to
my older sessions, you're going to
forget all this. And if you forget all
this, then how you going to answer the
questions? Here it is, black and white,
that the unclean animals pointed to the
pagans, the nations steeped in idolatry
that made them unclean spiritually.
On the next day,
Acts 10:9-16,
[clears throat] as they were on their
way and approaching the city, Peter went
up on the housetop about the sixth hour
to pray. But he became hungry and was
desiring to eat. And while they were
making preparations, he fell into a
trance. He saw heaven open up and an
object like a great sheet coming out
lowered by four corners to the ground
the earth. And there were in it all
kinds of for-footed animals and crawling
creatur creatures of the earth and birds
of the sky. And a voice came to him rise
up Peter slaughter and eat.
But Peter said by no means Lord for I
have never eaten anything defiled and
unclean. And again a voice came to him a
second time. What God has cleansed, no
longer consider defiled.
This happened three times and
immediately the object was taken up into
heaven. Now Peter was perplexed. He
didn't understand
what the vision meant. Why does God
saying the unclean animals are clean?
Don't call them unclean anymore. And why
three times? See, now I got to even show
you why three times. Here
you go. Here's why.
Now, while Peter was greatly perplexed
in mind as to what the vision which he
had seen might be, behold, the men had
been sent by Cornelius. Now, notice
these are Gentiles. They're pagans, and
the Jews cannot enter their home because
they'll be defiled. Having asked
directions for Simon's house, appeared
at the gate. calling out. They were
[clears throat] asking whether Simon,
who is also called Peter, was lodging
there. Now look how many men and they're
Gentiles. And while Peter was reflecting
on the vision, spirit said to him,
"Behold, three men,
Gentiles, are looking for you. But rise
up, go down, accompany them without
taking issue at all, for I have sent
them myself." Notice the Holy Spirit is
almighty God. He owns the church. He
tells the church what to do. He's
ordering Peter. Don't hesitate. Hurry
up. Go. Because I'm commanding you to go
and I'm the one who brought them. Notice
the work of the spirit. The spirit
brings you the message of salvation. And
the spirit sees your cries and then the
spirit sends you the right teacher. So
he goes, "I brought them because they're
looking for salvation and I appointed
you to teach them. Don't hesitate. Go."
Because Peter would have hesitated
because they're Gentiles. How many men?
Three men. What are they? Gentiles. How
many times he sees the vision? Three
times. Each time unclean animals. And
what did God say? Don't call anything
unclean that God has made clean. You see
why? Three times.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you so much, Sam. I appreciate.
>> We're not done yet. Don't take Oh,
shoot. Take it easy, man.
>> Sorry. Sorry.
>> Three times for the three men, right?
>> Yes. So the unclean animals represent
Gentiles, right?
>> Yes.
>> And God said they're no longer unclean.
Now three times, three men, but also
who makes you clean spiritually.
>> Christ,
>> father, son, holy spirit. Three times,
three divine persons, one God, three
Gentiles. And the work of cleansing
anyone is the work of the trinity.
That's why the spirit shows up to tell
Peter, "Go because I brought them." But
now, the proof that the animals
represent nations, when Peter enters
Cornelius's house, look what he says.
Acts 10:28.
>> And he said to them,
I want to bring you up. Take it easy. He
said to them, "You yourselves know how
unlawful it is for a man who is a Jew to
associate with a foreigner or to visit
him. Yet God has shown me that I should
not call any man defiled or unclean. So
brother, when did God show him, do not
call any man, no Gentile defiled or
unclean?
When did he show him?
>> He uh he said he he cleansed everything.
He made it clean. So you can't
>> When where where did he see it?
>> He saw it with the vision.
>> You got it. So the unclean animals
represented who?
the Gentiles.
>> And that's why he said, "Now I
understand because God showed me in a
vision, the Gentiles are not unclean."
So what did the animals represent? Clean
and unclean peoples.
So why didn't the Jews eat unclean
animals? In order God show them separate
from unclean people who are spiritually
unclean until they are cleansed.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> All right. Now, you got your answer,
dude. Even though it's on the topic.
>> Yeah. I'm sorry for going off topic, but
>> No, you you sorry. You It's your world.
Let me go to the Muslim kid now. You're
good.
>> Thank you, Sam.
>> All right. God bless. Pray for us.